an editor at state control channel 1 was
detained after interrupting this live
bulletin holding up a sign that read
stop the war
i want to thank everyone for their
support my friends and colleagues these
were uneasy days of my life because i
spent two days without sleep the
interrogation lasted for more than 14
hours was not allowed to contact my
relatives or provided with any judicial
help i was in a rather tough situation
i'll speak more tomorrow i just need to
rest today
the journalist who says her father is
ukrainian and mother russian received a
two hundred and eighty dollar fine
she food this message prior to the
protest
what is currently happening in ukraine
is a crime russia is a country aggressor
or responsibility for this aggression
lies on the conscience of one person
vladimir putin
unfortunately for the last several years
i worked at channel 1 promoting kremlin
propaganda and for that i'm very ashamed
right now i'm ashamed that i allowed
lies to be told from tv screens that i
allowed russian people to be zombified
the journalist pled not guilty to the
charge of organizing an unauthorized
public event
it's unclear whether she will face worse
consequences and other charges
her anti-war protest has been met with
global support
french president emmanuel macron has
offered the journalists asylum
while the ukrainian president thanked
her for her actions
i'm grateful to those russians who do
not stop trying to convey the truth to
those who fight disinformation and tell
the truth real facts to their friends
and loved ones and personally to the
woman who entered the studio of channel
1 with a poster against the war
the kremlin called her protest a form of
hooliganism
protests like these in moscow serving as
a stark example of how the country is
cracking down on free
speech what we're seeing right now is
that catastrophic rollback of
fundamental freedoms in russia
and the russian lawmakers very hastily
adopted new legislation
both installing a criminal penalties and
administrative penalties like fines
for um what they call discrediting
activities of russian military forces
but also for
uh knowingly disseminating fake
information about russian military
actions
that can carry a criminal penalty prison
time up to 15 years
but they start
from pretty hefty fines
and also a variety of different terms
based on the
so-called severity of the offense
the risk to stand up and speak out
weighing just as heavy as a guilt for
some in staying silent